je vous remercie beaucoup
juste les membres de la software
République se rassemblaient le 23
octobre à l'école 2006 an à Montini le
broteneux ils y présentaient leur
écosystème collaboratif de formation son
nom la talent académie ces teres ne vous
dis sûrement rien alors pour commencer
c'est quoi la software rublique c'est
une initiative qui a été lancée en avril
2021 par six grands groupes dasso
système eviden orange Renault group
stmic electronices et àè leur but faire
face au manque d'ingénieur en France
mais surtout au manque de jeunes sortant
de formations scientifique le but de la
softie publique c'est finalement de
faire ensemble des choses qu'on n'est
pas capable de faire tout seul d'abord
centré sur des produits des services
donc des activités je dirais d'ordre
plus business hein et puis finalement de
manière assez naturelle est venue la
question des compétences puisque pour
créer tous ces produits on a besoin de
compétences software on s'est rendu
compte qu'on en manquait tous et donc on
a décidé de s'allier pour également
euh augmenter je dirais notre tuyau de
de compétences dans le monde dans le
monde du software en faisant des actions
là encore en commun à ce jour il
manquerait près de 20000 nouveaux
ingénieurs diplômés en France selon le
syndicat STech ingénierie c'est là
qu'intervient la talent acadéie
l'objectif est simple susciter des
vocations et attirer les jeunes en
particulier les jeunes femmes vers le
monde de la technologie et de
l'industrie pour se faire la talent
academmie articule son programme autour
de trois grands axes l'éducation le
recrutement et la formation ils
correspondent aux trois moments clés
d'une carrière professionnelle donc tout
d'abord l'éducation donc pour ce pour
cela nous avons créé le programme
Factory qui est un programme dédié aux
jeunes quand je dis les jeunes ce sont
les 15 20 ans donc dès le collège on va
à la rencontre de de ces jeunes pour
essayer de susciter des des passions de
voilà autour des métiers de de
l'ingénierie auprès donc des des jeunes
et en particulier des jeunes filles pour
le recrutement c'est la talent incubator
qui s'en charge ce programme
d'apprentissage est dédié aux 20-25 ans
qui sont à la recherche de leur premier
emploi et enfin la formation avec la
talent accélérator qui intervient en
cours de carrière nous avons le
programme accélérateur qui là est un
programme de formation continue dédié à
l'ensemble des collaborateurs des six
entrepr prise de la softwire Rpublique
et là nous avons comme objectif de
former 40000 collaborateurs à horizon
2025 et donc la talent academmie de
softwire rpubli est un pilier
complémentaire aux politiques de
ressources humaines qui existe dans nos
entreprise et qui va permettre
d'atteindre cet objectif ambitieux parmi
ceux qui ont intégré ce projet il y a
Victor Verdet apprenti à l'école 2600 et
membre de la talent incubator il fait
partie de l'équipe software publ de chez
Renault group pour lui intégrer ce
programme a été une chance il s'agit du
premier écosystème collaboratif de
formation mis en place par de grands
groupes concrètement ça nous on est
convié à des à des événements on est
convié à des à des voilà des conférences
des des formations voilà rencontrer les
d'autres alternans et d'autres
experts d'autres écoles qui font partie
de la talent Academy donc ça multiplie
encore plus notre réseau futur et à côté
de ça ce qui ce qui est super
intéressant c'est que la sauire
République
nous nous propose du du matériel etah
des experts pour venir enseigner et
aussi pour qu'on puisse bah s'exercer
cette initiative est inédite en France
et en Europe il s'agit du premier
écosystème collaboratif de formation mis
en place par de grands groupes